48 miles in 48 hours
by the way i just want to say how much i
admire
your willingness to keep this kind of
hardcore attitude
um i know that russians have it and
russian jews have it in spades but it's
harder to do
in a society that's sloppy and that's
weak
and that's lazy and the fact that you
bring so much heart
to saying i'm going to bring this to jiu
jitsu i'm going to bring this to guitar
i'm going to bring this to ai i'm going
to bring this to podcasting
it comes through loud and clear and i
just find it completely and utterly
inspiring that you keep this kind of
hardcore
aspect at the same time that you're the
guy who's extolling the virtue of love
in a modern society and doing it at
scale
thank you that means a lot i don't know
why i'm doing it but i'm just following
my heart on it
and just going with a gut it seems to
make sense somehow i i personally think
we better get tougher
or we're going to get in a world of pain
and i i do think that when it comes time
to lead
it's great to have people who you know
don't crack under pressure
you